welcome to this video playing crows from
Norway right yeah i was a bit irritated
there was one chromis some time ago and
he had the he was from Iceland this is
why i was a bit irritated okay we have
something like that she Goran but I
haven't played c-4 would do that next
move this kind of firm position is some
always um somewhere between very
slightly better provided equal black gum
has good piece of development so it's
not really in bad shape the knight on c6
is always a bit weird but okay all your
pieces are all right he took on c4 down
this is surprising me slightly but it's
not the end of the world you can always
straight them trade something and
relieve some pressure queen is she going
to play me five and here may be a good
play Bishop b5 trying to prevent that
maybe not not so sure how to proceed
this pin Bishop g4 pinning the night is
a bit a bit annoying I thought I had
prevented that as usual it it's probably
not the case oh I didn't didn't think
about that move at all okay but anyway
that's am continue it certainly is not
the end of the world ok I take on d6
yeah this would straighten the pawn
structure yeah probably just just castle
if he takes on f3 I don't really mind
that at some my king position is
reasonably safe with the bishop on g3
and I didn't really want to take on on
d6 and to correct his pawn structure to
rather plain maybe look before
yeah I didn't expect that move it on is
he threatening to take here probably not
a half 95 look before i can take d 6
it's not really a threat I think
yeah I can take now here and then you
need to take with the Queen which is not
too desirable so um where to go now I
can't simply trade yes it's not bad I
mean it's still a good bone structure
for me come on let's let's keep it to
keep it simple the hanging pots with
them now some pieces exchange to should
be good enough for the slide slide
something and that didn't want to make
it too complicated
look Dee one king in seven no probably I
need to be quicker than that yes I was
thinking maybe II 493 85 the scandal
idea we are but a 4 a 4 is told to play
no question that's hard to to do
anything against it though I can only
put the night on be tuned this is a
quite passive okay maybe anyway play
daddy for an ID see phone if I go efore
a 45 takes Knight takes how this is
actually ok
if I go e five takes Knight xiah take a
four and the rook so um he may be needs
to react to me five it goes night d 7 I
can maybe donate be to attending night
see form I'd also stopping a 45 the
moment 95 I have f4 maybe ya know if I
if this was what i was thinking of been
trying to open up yeah now the spin this
was one idea it slightly annoying night
came sim can you move it very well
probably can
okay still after the night moves and in
exchange I have rope d5 at the other
ticking the weak bone again it still
rather passive or black
kindy six nights ago and he cannot move
the 1994 check
yeah I want this important pawn check
stopping Kings III check and don't think
this helps I have say three now check
just covering a three and then a four
get the pawns ruling check
and I can go to her phone no pain ok
anyway push the airport
ok now we need to react them exactly um
what now night c4 is goody for checkin
saucer bit embarrassing
maybe here Knight c3 coming check yeah
check I hope thus winning I mean if it
takes a seven-day sir I think a
promotion and otherwise i play be five I
can also take you find all the finest on
time yeah i think it's it's going down
yeah it is yeah he gave away the a porn
but it was always a bit of a bit of
pressure of course the question is if I
really should trade on d6 a.m. but I
didn't really see how I could
alternative and this means that black is
probably a probably okay around him he
should be able to defend who came I
think this was a good idea of intending
ye five so he covered that and then I
dropped back looking at those squares
and then while here and this should this
should be probably not the end of the
world would like but this is not so easy
to defend in a practical game and he
quite quickly gave up gave up the apron
and Jamie this basically losses no way
to to say that after that but it was
probably still okay yeah I always have
this weakness to play against but we
should be able to defend alright thanks
for watching